Ahoy word Smiths hold fast because this
word is about keeping it Steady As She
Goes maintain is the featured word oh I
maintain a steady course word Smith's
maintain it's a verb it means to keep
something the same to provide support
for something so to maintain a course if
you're steering a vessel is to keep us
going in the same direction you might
also see it as maintenance which is the
noun form now this word comes to us
through French But ultimately from Latin
maintain comes from Manu ten to hold in
the hand uh and so man means hand and
ten or Tain means hold when you're
maintaining something you're putting
your hands on it you're holding on to it
to keep it steady in some way although
you don't always have to literally put
your hands on something to maintain it
let's take those two word Parts Main and
10 or Tain and see what we can make out
of them I'll put on some music and you
and I will go go and think about some
related words 10 seconds here we
go all right here's what I've got
manuscript which is a handwritten
document right means to write Manu means
hand a handwritten thing abstain AB
means from and Tain means to hold to
abstain from something is to hold back
I'm abstaining from tackle football
because I bruise easily manipulate this
word means to handle or control
something or someone as though you're
controlling it with your hands it can be
both literal and figurative you can
manipulate a device by pushing its
buttons or you can manipulate a person
by trying to control them in a sneaky
way now let us push the button labeled
example sentences to see what maintain
looks like in
context to maintain the balance in her
garden soil Vanessa added eggshells to
her compost pile so she's trying to keep
things steady in the compost pile she's
trying to make sure the mix of nutrients
is right to make good soil uh but let's
also talk about maintenance which
usually has a mechanical meaning like
keeping a vehicle in good condition Ah
that's a fine motorbike an antique
motorcycle requires constant maintenance
you have to be cleaning and oiling and
working on it all the time that's
maintenance keeping it in steady working
condition keep your minds in steady
working condition wordsmiths hands on
the tiller eyes on the horizon love the
main sail other boat things you can
learn anything David out